[Music]
straight ahead all on crime daily
mariah carey is facing a legal battle
over a popular christmas song nearly
three decades after its release plus two
men convicted of robbing and bearing a
florida couple alive more than 15 years
ago will face a courtroom again as jury
selection begins in the re-sentencing
trial of alan wade and michael jackson
and a georgia man acquitted of murder is
facing new charges as the complicated
case of the murder of tara grinstead
continues but first we're seeing the
first impacts of the jury's verdict in
johnny depp's defamation case against
ex-wife amber hurd how the washington
post is responding to the outcome law on
crime daily covering court cases from
coast to coast
welcome everyone to law enforcement
daily i'm your host brian buckmeyer
after a jury ruled primarily in johnny
depp's favor in his defamation suit
against ex-wife amber hurd the
washington post made a notable change to
the online op-ed article at the center
of the case
after nearly two months of testimony a
jury found amber hearn liable on three
counts stemming from her allegations of
abuse by depp in a washington post
article published in 2018. depp filed a
lawsuit against heard saying the article
which did not mention him by name
defamed him causing him to lose work and
struggle financially testimony for a
debt side also argued hurd abused him on
a number of occasions hurd in turn filed
a counter suit saying statements made in
the daily mail by depp's attorney adam
waldman defamed her ultimately the jury
awarded depp 50 million dollars in
damages and awarded 2 million dollars to
herd for her counter suit after the
verdict the washington post added an
editor's note to the article detailing
the three statements depp claimed were
false and defamatory and
the note also mentions the outcome of
the trial heard has 30 days to appeal
the verdict which her attorney says she
plans to do
joining us today is georgia prosecutor
and city council candidate latonya hines
and co-host terry austin latonya the
editor's note reads to me like the
washington post is just kind of covering
themselves from being sued is that the
case or is it something else
i mean i think it's both things i think
it's
caring themselves for being sued but
also at the same time they're trying to
also be journalists good journalists and
coming back and reporting what actually
occurred so that you give a little bit
of context about the story um and i
think it was a smart move on their move
uh to go ahead and do that
yeah terry i'm just an attorney
pretending to be a journalist so i guess
my question is wouldn't it just be
better to fully retract amber heard's
article wouldn't that be a better
decision at the end of the day
oh i definitely think it would have been
a better decision but it was a decision
i think that was based both on probably
legal advice and probably financial
concerns because you know the team of
lawyers is going to say look you need to
put a statement or you need to retract
it those are the two main options a
statement allows the article to stay
posted and it brings readers to the
paper and so frankly i think having the
statement still there knowing that the
jury has said that several of the
comments in that post article are
defamatory it allows the washington post
to have its cake and to eat it too they
can keep the article up people will come
to read the article they know all about
the johnny depp amber heard case and
they're going to want to read the
article to see what it said and having
that statement at the top is going to
protect the washington post so i
definitely think that they got advice
from everyone but i do think that their
pocketbook was part of that
decision-making process absolutely and
of course having the article out there
with the disclaimer gives full context
people can read the disclaimer as well
as the article and see what it's all
about the other day and hey more
information is always the best i think
in these types of situations thank you
both and in south carolina tiger king's
star doc antl has been arrested by the
fbi and is facing federal money
laundering charges anto is the owner of
the myrtle beach safari featured in the
2020 netflix documentary series tiger
king murder mayhem and madness the show
focused on tigers breeders and private
zoo owners across the country including
oklahoma zoo operator joseph allen
maldonado passage better known as joe
exotic exotic was previously convicted
and sentenced to 21 years behind bars in
a plot to kill animal welfare activist
carol baskin animal rights activists
have accused joe exotic and dr antle of
of mistreating lions and other wildlife
anto was indicted two years ago on
felony animal cruelty and wildlife
trafficking charges he's scheduled to go
to trial in that case next month he now
faces money laundering charges after a
non-profit people for the ethical
treatment of animals or peta asked the
irs to probe his rare species fund anto
and two others are accused of laundering
over 500 thousand dollars believed to be
proceeds from an illegal immigrant
smuggling operation across the u.s
mexico border anto has a history of
violations going back over 30 years he's
faced more than 35 u.s department of
agriculture violations for mistreatment
of animals
and switching coasts to california as a
trial for the man accused of killing
rapper nipsey hussell gets underway in
los angeles after three years of delays
defendant eric holder will face a jury
for the first time on charges of first
degree murder attempted murder and
assault with a deadly weapon he has pled
not guilty to all charges holder was
arrested in april 2019 less than a week
after he allegedly shot nipsy hustle in
front of the rapper's marathon clothing
store police say a dispute broke out
between the two men after nipsy hustle
accused holder of being a snitch
investigators say a holder left the
store and then returned with two guns a
revolver and a black semi-automatic a
medical examiner found nimcy hustle was
shot at least 10 times with the bullets
piercing his lungs and severing his
spinal cord a witness alleges holder
told nipsey hustle after the shots were
fired quote you're through the judge
previously ruled there will be limited
media coverage allowed of the trial
during jury selection is expected to
stretch into next week holder faces life
in prison if convicted
still ahead on law and crime daily two
florida men face re-sentencing after
being convicted and initially sentenced
to death for the murder committed nearly
17 years ago
but first a popular christmas song is
the topic of a new lawsuit wyatt man
alleges mariah carey stole his song
title in the 90s
[Music]
welcome back to long crime daily pop
star mariah carey is facing legal issues
as she's being sued by another artist
over her hit song titled all i want for
christmas is you the artist argues he
wrote a song by the same title years
before her holiday hint was released
andy stone who performs as vince vance
with the country pop band vince vance
and the valiants doesn't argue that the
songs have similar lyrics or even the
same
or sound the same just that they have
the exact same title stone is seeking at
least 20 million dollars in damages from
carrie her co-writer and sony music
entertainment for copyright infringement
and misappropriation he claims he owns
the copyright on the title all i want
for christmas is you stone's song was
released in 1989 while carrie's song
came out five years later in 1994. all i
want for christmas is you has earned
carrie more than 60 million dollars in
royalties since its release it's unclear
why stone has made the legal challenge
now 28 years after carrie's song was
released
terry let's start off with that question
right off the bat why now online for
christmas has been out since the mid 90s
since i was writing santa claus letters
is the timing going to affect this case
at all as to how old it is
well that's an excellent question brian
copyrights are governed by federal law
because under the u.s patent and
trademark and copyright office obviously
it's a federal issue the statute of
limitations there is three years no
matter what from the date of the last
act of infringement we're in louisiana
here that's the fifth circuit they
followed the discovery rule so the
statute actually starts to run when
someone discovers or should have
discovered that there was a copyright
infringement but the interesting thing
is here this really should have been a
trademark case because copyright really
protects a work of art this is just a
title or a phrase which is generally
protected by a trademark so it should be
booted just based on the fact that it's
the wrong cause of action yeah i guess
i'll tell you we kind of got part of it
there but the argument is only about the
title of the song not the lyrics so how
can you copyright or trademark as terry
has just taught us what seems to be such
a generic phrase
it's very generic i mean look at it
we've had a lot of songs like jump i
mean you've got at least three different
artists who've done a song named jump
van halen crisscross madonna so i think
it makes it very hard to just say the
name itself makes it a trademark uh onto
itself for purposes of getting royalties
usually it's about the melody whether or
not you're using the same
music uh that is in another uh song
that's been copyrighted or whatever i
think it's gonna be very hard especially
28 years later to now bring this suit up
and especially about a title
yeah i mean maybe i'm biased but that's
mariah's song so we're going to figure
out how this is going to play out but
i'm on team moriah on this one we'll see
how the lawyers decide it though
switching gears now to new hampshire as
the stepmother of a missing child
harmony montgomery waved her arraignment
on new charges monday just the day
before the girl's birthday police
believe harmony has been missing since
late 2019 while she was in her father
adam montgomery's custody in early 2020
officials say adam told child protective
services harmony had been living with
her money her mother crystal sorry
harmony wasn't officially reported
missing until november 2021
no one has been charged in relation to
her disappearance but caleb montgomery
adam's estranged wife has faced welfare
fraud charges accused of claiming
harmony as a member of her household
even though she was not living with her
and adam at the time kayla now faces
perjury charges for allegedly lying to a
grand jury harmony's eighth birthday is
tuesday anyone with information about
harmony's disappearance can call or text
the 24-hour tip line at the bottom of
your screen
and in minnesota two former cops charged
in the death of george floyd won't face
trial until 2023 the judge's ruling to
delay two tao and j alexander king's
trial until january next year comes less
than a month after their fellow former
officer thomas lane pled guilty in the
state case against them
while the judge denied a request to move
the trial to a different county he did
say publicity surrounding the federal
conviction and lane's guilty plea is
quote particularly troublesome and does
create a reasonable likelihood of an
unfair trial the judge has already set
specific dates for the trial to begin in
mid-january the three former minneapolis
police officers were convicted by a
federal jury of civil rights violations
just four months ago lane king and tao
were fellow officers of ex-cop derek
chovin who was tried last year in state
court of killing george floyd in 2020
when he knelt on his neck for more than
nine minutes during an attempted arrest
floyd's death sparked nationwide
protests and debate over use of force by
police officers shoving was sentenced to
22 and a half years in prison all four
officers are awaiting sentencing for the
federal charges
coming up on law and crime daily
convicted murderers will soon learn
their new fate as jury selection begins
in the re-sentencing trial of alan wade
and michael jackson plus ryan duke is
acquitted of killing but now faces new
charges in a neighboring georgian county
in relation to the death of tara
grinstead
[Music]
welcome back jury selection begins in
the trial of a florida woman accused of
stabbing her husband to death in their
home in 2019. danielle redlich faces
second-degree murder charges and
tampering with evidence charges in the
stabbing death of her husband michael
redlich investigators say redlich called
911 initially telling dispatchers her
husband had a heart attack after the two
had an altercation in 911 calls she
claimed michael stabbed himself and that
she woke up next to him deceased but
investigators believe michael's wounds
were not self-inflicted and that
danielle tried to clean up the crime
scene before calling 9-1-1 the
65-year-old was previously married to
danielle's mother while she suffered and
eventually succumbed to cancer he also
worked as the director of the university
of central florida sports business
management program prosecutors offered
danielle a plea deal to plead guilty to
manslaughter charges two years ago but
she rejected it on monday the judge read
danielle's charges to the group of
prospective jurors
this is the state of florida versus
danielle justine redlich
it charges count number one
second-degree murder with a firearm
count two tampering with physical
evidence
i misspoke
it's second degree murder with a weapon
and then tampering with physical
evidence
it alleges that danielle justine redlich
on the 11th day of january 2019 or the
12th day of january 2019
in orange county florida
by an act imminently dangerous to
another
and evincing a depraved mind regardless
of human life
did kill michael redlich and in the
course of committing said offense
danielle justine redlich did carry
display
use
threaten to use or attempt to use a
weapon
once the jury is selected opening
statements could begin as early as
wednesday
and jury selection begins in another
florida case the death penalty phase
retrial for two men convicted in a 2005
double murder allen wayne and michael
james jackson are two of four people
involved in the deaths of reggie and
carol sumner alan wade michael james
jackson tiffany cole and bruce nixon
were all convicted over a decade ago for
their involvement in the murder cole was
the connection between all the players
involved as she previously had been the
summoner's neighbor before the couple
moved to jacksonville cole argues
jackson hatched the plan to break into
the couple's home while they were away
but that plan evolved into killing them
prosecutors argued at the defendant's
trial that the four dug a hole in a
remote wooded spot in georgia before
kidnapping the sumners the group stole
from reggie and carol's home then forced
them into the trunk of their own car
then in two separate cars the summoners
and a rental the foursome drove reggie
and carroll to the remote location they
forced the couple to share their bank
account information before bearing them
alive wade jackson and cole were all
sentenced to death for the murder nixon
took a plea deal pleading guilty to
second-degree murder now wade in jackson
will be re-sentenced after a change in
florida law which requires a unanimous
jury decision for the death penalty
terry how much of the fact that florida
juries now need to be unanimous to
change this re-sentencing child does it
mean that it's gonna be a lot harder for
the prosecution to secure
a death penalty i guess
you know i don't think it's going to be
harder i think that they're going to
have to put in evidence to show what
exactly occurred and make the jury
understand that this was a heinous crime
and that they're going to have to get a
conviction and it's going to be the
penalty rather is having to be uh
unanimous you can't have not even one
juror say no death penalty so i think
that the prosecution is going to look at
this they're going to make sure that all
the evidence gets in they're going to
see whether or not they have mitigating
facts and you know factors that are
aggravating to make sure that this jury
totally understands that it has to be
unanimous
and for the defense they'll be saying we
just need one now latonya you helped
prosecute the men responsible for the
death of a mod arbory and you've seen
your fair share of trials my
understanding is that we're going to
have two juries here in a single trial
how does that work and why is that going
on
because we have a bifurcated system when
you have the first part of it is the
trial part and you deal with whether or
not somebody's convicted and then you're
going to have the part dealing with the
penalty phase and that's the issue here
is that they're doing a re-sentencing
with regard to the penalty phase whether
or not they actually get the death
penalty or not and so that's why you
have the two different juries
all right we'll see what this jury
decides as they evaluate terry you said
it best the prosecution's gonna present
all that evidence and see how they come
to that conclusion of death or no death
and of course florida laws have changed
requiring that to be unanimous so we'll
keep track on this not that michael
jackson you're probably thinking of
michael james jackson and alan wade the
death penalty charges in out of florida
when we come back new charges for a
georgia man acquitted of murder last
month we'll discuss the case of ryan
dukes and botus charge in relation to
the death and disappearance of tara
grinstead
[Music]
welcome back just two weeks after a
georgia man was acquitted of murdering a
beauty queen and teacher 17 years ago
he's facing new charges in a neighboring
county ryan duke faced an irwin county
jury last month for tara grinstead's
murder but was ultimately charged with
concealing her death duke pointed the
finger at his former friend and
classmate beau dukes who is already
serving 25 years in prison on charges
related to the case grinstead went
missing in 2005 but her disappearance
remained a mystery for more than a
decade at ryan duke's trial last month
he told jurors he lied when he confessed
to the teacher's murder in 2017 but
admitted to helping beau dukes dispose
of her body by burning it in a pecan
orchard at a nearby county duke now
faces six new charges in neighboring
bent hill county including concealing
the death of another hindering
apprehension or punishment of a criminal
concealment of facts and tampering with
evidence in the irwin county case duke
was sentenced to 10 years in prison he
faces more prison time if convicted in
ben hill county beau dukes also faces
charges in ben hill county the trial for
those charges is set to start as early
as the end of june
help us make heads or tales of this how
does this work a defendant serving time
in one county but indicted for the same
death is that in a different county
sorry is that double jeopardy or is that
allowed
i mean it's allowed in certain cases
because you're saying
that
information that happened new
information's come out new evidence has
come out that something actually
happened in this particular county that
venue lies here this is where the actual
crime occurred and what we're talking
about here is specifically about the
concealment of death and that
information came up by him his own
admission on the stand of saying where
it occurred in ben hill county and so
now you've got new charges there based
off of this information right so
probably death in one county concealing
another and that's how they're kind of
splitting it up terry should we be
expecting the same case and same result
in a different county since things are
so similar or is this completely
different in all matters in this the
bent hill county case
you know i think it's going to be a very
similar case because there are very
similar charges two different counties
like you said erwin county where we saw
this case and then ben hill county where
we'll see the second case i think most
of that evidence in the second case is
going to be focusing on like it was in
the first case what occurred after the
murder who handled the body who told who
to do what and i think that basically
the big issue here is the fact that
neither county brought murder charges we
know there was a confession and it seems
to me that the prosecution missed an
opportunity in both counties to bring
charges for murder in this case so i
think that was a big missed opportunity
yeah we'll see how they make out with
that in this case thank you both and
thank you for joining us here on law and
crime daily we'll see you next time as
we discuss justice in america
[Music]
you